so I might regret doing this story but I
do think it's worthwhile and I think
it's the type of thing we really should
be doing every once in a while you might
not have heard of rising conservative
superhero Candace Owens she's been
making the rounds on lots of the online
talk shows I think she's appeared some
places with Dave Rubin maybe Jordan
Peterson I'm not totally sure about that
one she's being sort of hailed as some
kind of unique truth teller who has I
guess because she's black to some degree
broken through the indoctrination that
maybe the right feels leads black
Americans to overwhelmingly vote
Democratic I don't know but she has
fought her way out of it and she is now
a conservative so I actually don't even
really find her blackness relevant to my
analysis whatsoever there's no doubt
that the right loves examples of black
people with the quote correct views that
they can point to partially to prove how
not racist they are this includes people
like you know Larry elder who's been
doing the rounds lately and others but I
think it's actually more interesting to
look at how the right has embraced her
despite what her blisteringly uninformed
and quite frankly dumb opinions on
endless issues I care about her ideas
not her identity even though the right
the alt-right the new anti sjw right has
basically become an identity movement
that claims to be against identity
politics let's forget about that I care
about her ideas and what I want to play
for you and really what I want to do is
think through what she's saying I'm
gonna play for you parts of a recent
interview she did on Joe Rogan's podcast
and to his credit Joe Rogan does offer
some pushback to some of the idiocy that
she spouts not nearly enough and he has
been I don't know exactly what his
politics are but he has provided an
environment that has really incubated
horrible alt-right ideas maybe without
even realizing it he does offer some
pushback here
let's dig into this and you're going to
very quickly see how there is no
substance whatsoever here eight Walker's
at the wall but I understand how you
think that we
you were almost losing America and
there's a battle for America I really
thought that like just in in every
regard in terms of just just the people
that were running like Hillary Clinton
like this woman was a globalist like to
think about who we were who we were in
bed with like Saudi Arabia selling all
of our uranium to Russia
like like okay it's uh buried there
already more nonsense than anybody but
Trump could stuff into twenty seconds
right Joe Rogan wants to know how we're
losing America she says she really feels
that we are isn't she part of the ben
shapiro facts don't care about your
feelings movement like how is it
relevant that she feels that we're
losing america so in the first twenty
seconds she says feelings dictate her
beliefs she says hillary clinton was a
globalist a term with no meaning
straight out of alex jones as conspiracy
theories how was Trump not a globalist
by these exact same standards and then
she uncritically repeats the debunked
Hillary Clinton uranium one conspiracy
theory nothing from Rogan this is the
hero
Candace Owens that the right is now
holding up so now I guess she starts
doing what maybe we would call like a
policy analysis of some kind
take a look like Trump came in and was
like no like America people we weren't
the gap like we lost them
we're losing the middle class a gap
between the rich and the poor was like
literally what do you think is causing
that policies shipping all of our jobs
overseas the regulation the government
getting bigger and better you can't do
anything as an entrepreneur entrepreneur
in America without a piece of paper from
the government discouraging people with
a piece of paper extending like shutting
down the factories from getting that
there's something you know there's a
little land between New York and LA I
believe it or not like you know and this
is what Trump understood
these are manic rantings right it she's
throwing ten things at the wall to see
what sticks it would be great for Joe
Rogan to break it down one by one
because then he could say well which
factories have been shut down and who
shut them down are you saying the
government shut down factories was it
Obama and now Trump's doing well by not
shutting them down she points out well
there's a big gap between the rich and
poor yeah that's a bad thing but that's
because of right-wing policies and it's
because of the policies that are similar
to the ones Trump has been pushing right
shipping jobs overseas regulation huge
government entrepreneurs can't do
anything
can't do anything without a piece of
paper none of these are arguments right
there was not an argument that's
actually being made its total Gish
gallop nonsense and then she goes
totally off the rails and in explaining
how she was converted from her false
liberal beliefs to I guess her correct
right-wing beliefs she goes fully
ignorant on climate change and finally
Joe Rogan I guess feels he has no choice
but to step in and Trump appealed to
that those people I'm still floored like
as I'm traveling the world and seeing
different pieces of the country I'm
learning how ignorant I was like and
that's the best thing in the entire
world just I fell victim to the idea
that like it was progress it was
progress it was progress we have to care
about the environment it was progress
and it's like no like we've been losing
America has been losing and Donald Trump
understood that and in a way that I
didn't and I think we have to care about
the environment not even a little bit
okay let me clarify this I don't throw
trash on the ground like we need to like
you know trash the environment like but
do I believe in climate change no you
don't I'm not saying throw your trash
out the window but I am saying that
climate change is fake so then we get
into this in more detail right Joe Rogan
says let's explore that and this is how
it goes you don't believe in climate
change no I think the climate always
changes I guess especially do I believe
it this is like you know an issue that
is being global warming which they've
changed community they got rid of the
word one sign to started disproving it
now they only say client climate change
now I think that that was just a way to
extract dollars from Americans I don't
at all believe they had no actionable
plan it was great for Trump dig out of
that deal it was terrible okay but this
is an incredibly complicated subject
right and if you would have to talk to a
bunch of different scientists and see
how they gather data and see what they
understand about co2 levels and what's
the danger of them and what can combat
it and what could not have you done all
this around Flippen opinion this is not
this wouldn't be the hill I died on
right but it's not about part I just
genuinely I've read a ton about it but I
would not be able to I would not be able
to come to you and say like this is my
strong opinion but here's like the
easiest way to say this right she says I
wouldn't be able to come to you and say
this is my strong opinion she just said
Phin ative li that she thinks the entire
climate change consensus involving
ninety-nine point nine six of climates
night and percent of climate scientists
is hoax to extract money from americans
but she's not going to go to joe and say
she has a strong opinion on the issue
what new conservative hero Candice Owens
she has said nothing in the first couple
of minutes of video I've played for you
here other than spouting conspiracy
theories and saying she doesn't trust
climate scientists and then here is the
goldmine the fact that there is a
disparity and the Science Committee but
whether or not it's real is enough to
very little yet very little disparity
most most does most scientists most the
the vast majority agree that human
beings are negatively affecting climate
change yeah the vast majority yeah I
don't I just don't think so
you so you think that the very few
scientists that disagree with the
consensus are the ones that are correct
well I think if something is it's it's
either subjective or its objective and
their objective truths right there it is
again I just don't think so that's not
an argument
I thought facts didn't care about your
feelings or of what you thought of them
and then of course for all the criticism
of post-modernism from this new free
speech warrior contingent of the right
she goes postmodern on us by saying
there are objective truths and so
there's the objective and subjective
it's not wrong but it's completely
cherry-picking
that from a philosophy that these people
claim is horrible in order to get out
from under Joe Rogan's criticism of her
ignorant beliefs and then she says any
dot-coms can't be trusted but dot orgs
can as long as you're trying to deny
climate change dr. Robert Schoch
2014 the vast majority eighty seven
percent of scientists said that human
activity is driving global warming yet
only half the American public public
ascribed to that view so what website
eighty seven percent and this is
Scientific American yeah yeah calm
though like that means it's it's making
money I don't trust that if it was a dot
org I would probably take necessarily a
random website yeah I don't I don't
believe this like at all just so you
know you don't believe it like I did I
genuinely I genuinely don't believe I
know you do but I genuinely don't
believe it right if she doesn't believe
the
claims about climate change from every
anybody that's making money then she has
to stop believing all those climate
science climate science denying
scientists who are paid by the fossil
fuel industry she has to deny any claims
about climate change from for-profit
companies like the fossil fuel companies
themselves these are not arguments and
an interesting question for her would be
you don't believe scientists you don't
believe coms you really think it's not
real what would change your mind what
would change your mind and it just goes
on and on like this for a very long time
I'm not gonna play how long was this
entire interview Pat it was was it like
a it's a three hour show yeah yeah we're
obviously not going to do that but I
will play one other moment for you where
she seems to be arguing that opinions
are by definition uninformed and that's
actually what's at the crux of a lot of
the silly intellectual darkweb and free
speech warrior movement take a look I
said but this is what you're saying you
don't believe yeah I would have to have
someone sit down and convince me that it
was real I personally don't believe it
that's okay why it's good to start not
believing something no it's not you
think you should start with believing
everything oh it's did not believe
either or not believe yes not believe no
but don't say you don't believe yeah
learn about it yeah learn about it and
then have an opinion but you're stating
this opinion without having any real
understanding what climates but that's
that's exactly what an opinion is I'm
not going like I said if you said that
Canada she went on to 10,000 college
campuses and you said that globerman
wasn't real then we'd have a problem you
and I just having a conversation Joe
Rogan says you're stating an opinion
without having any justifying evidence
for it and she says that's what opinions
are there is this conflation of healthy
skepticism with the distrust of science
combined with the idea that all opinions
are just equally someone's feelings
about something right and that's how you
get the Candice's opinion that climate
change isn't real is the same as a
climate scientists opinion based on all
the data that climate change is real and
caused by humans this is mind-numbing
Lee ignorant but it's really dangerous
because this person is becoming a
conservative hero she's proud of having
uninformed opinions she's bragging about
how she has this opinion totally
uninformed by fact and this is part of
the anti and pseudo-intellectual ism of
this new movement that
we've been extensively covering because
of how dangerous it is they say we think
they're dangerous because they're
finally telling some truth that nobody
else will tell know they're dangerous
because it's making people who don't
know anything the heroes of others who
also don't know anything and it's the
blind leading the blind and for people
saying well then David you're not being
fair have Iran she's welcome on the
program absolutely any time I'm glad to
have her on and we can explore what
constitutes justified beliefs and what
doesn't and talk about any issue she
wants to this is what we're fighting and
lastly I actually sort of questioned
whether she's even really had this
incredible enlightenment I think that
she was probably sort of casually on the
left and then realized that hey there's
this entire thing that she can do where
she is a conservative and she goes out
and says this stuff and it's really
appealing to a lot of people I don't
even know that I buy the background
story or maybe she's 80% conservative
and just adding on all the extra talking
points like the one about climate change
maybe saying it's interesting like Joe
Rogan he's probably more liberal than
conservative but he definitely has
conservative tendencies yeah and so they
were getting along for a lot of that
time I watched the whole thing
the first hour or so they were getting
along quite well and then they got to
this issue of the environment because
she felt really comfortable in that safe
space right and that's where Joe Rogan
had to go off you you you can't really
hide in that three-hour platform
total implosion I mean total total and
absolute utter implosion send me your
thoughts what am I missing about Candice
Owens the video you just finished
watching was made possible by you
through the membership program you can
sign up for membership at david
pakman.com slash membership we are
viewer supported independent media you
can use the coupon code
I voted 17 for a 40% discount off of
your membership